BACK TO YOU.
>> LOOK, EVERYONE IS SO LUCKY
THAT THEY'RE THERE AND WILLING
TO SERVE.
GARY TUCHMAN, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
>>> NEW GUIDANCE OUT FROM THE
CDC UPDATES THE GUIDANCE FOR
PEOPLE WHO TEST POSITIVE FOR
COVID.
WE SAY GUIDANCE, BUT HOW MUCH OF
A GUIDE IS IT REALLY?
HAS IT REALLY CLEARED UP THE
CONFUSION?
THE CDC NOW SAYS PEOPLE WHO TEST
POSITIVE SHOULD SELF-ISOLATE FOR
AT LEAST FIVE DAYS.
THOSE WHO WANT TO TAKE A TEST
SHOULD DO SO AT THE END OF THE
FIVE DAYS.
IF THE TEST COMES BACK POSITIVE,
BUT ONLY IF YOU CHOSE TO TAKE
IT, RIGHT.
>> OPTIONAL.
>> THE PERSON SHOULD CONTINUE TO
ISOLATE FOR A TOTAL OF 10 DAYS.
THE GUIDANCE STOPPED SHORT FOR
EVERYONE TO GET TESTED BEFORE
LEAVING ISOLATION.
IF I GET A BAD JOB EXPLAINING
WHAT THE GUIDANCE IS, IT'S NOT
MY FAULT, TRUST ME.
JOINING ME NOW CNN CHIEF MEDICAL
CORRESPONDENT DR. SANJAY GUPTA
AND AUTHOR OF "KEEP KEEP SHARP,
BUILD A BETTER BRAIN AT ANY
AGE."
THEY HAVE HAD A REALLY TOUGH JOB
THE LAST FEW YEARS.
BUT I CAN'T UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY
ARE SAYING AND WHY.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN IT?
AND.
>> WELL, UNFORTUNATELY, JOHN, IT
IS PRETTY CONFUSING.
IT IS GOING TO CREATE THESE
LINES AS WE HAVE SEEN THROUGHOUT
THE PANDEMIC.
IF YOU WANT TO DO THE RIGHT
THING AND YOU CAN GET YOUR HANDS
ON A TEST, YOU WILL DO THE RIGHT
THING.
BUT A LOT OF PEOPLE WON'T.
IT IS CERTAINLY NOT
INCENTIVIZING IT.
AND I THINK THIS COMES BACK TO
THE ORIGINAL SIN, YOU KNOW, THAT
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE SORT OF
FRAMED AROUND TESTING.
WE'VE NEVER HAD ENOUGH TESTING.
DR. WALENSKY, HEAD OF THE CDC,
SAID THIS ISN'T ABOUT SHORTAGE
OF TESTS.
BUT, LOOK, IF PEOPLE HAD TESTS
IN THEIR HOME, IF WE ARE ABLE TO
TRACK THE TEST SINCE THE
BEGINNING, WE WOULD BE IN A
DIFFERENT POSITION.
IT MAKES TOTAL SENSE FOR TESTING
TO BE A PART OF THE RETURN TO
LIFE SORT OF PROTOCOLS.
BUT UNFORTUNATELY WE STILL --
YOU HEARD ABOUT THE 500 MILLION
TESTS THAT WILL GO OUT AT SOME
POINT.
HOPEFULLY THAT HAPPENS.
BUT IT IS STILL NOT GOING TO BE
ENOUGH TESTS.
IT COULD LAST A COUPLE OF CYCLES
FOR PEOPLE OF TESTING.
WE NEED A LOT OF TESTS.
WE DON'T HAVE THEM.
AND I THINK THAT'S WHY YOU GET
FUZZY GUIDELINES.
>> LOOK, EITHER THEY THINK YOU
NEED A NEGATIVE TEST OR YOU
DON'T.
THAT'S WHAT IS SO WEIRD ABOUT
THIS.
>> RIGHT.
>> IF THEY THINK IT IS BECAUSE
YOU MIGHT GET A FALSE POSITIVE,
JUST SAY IT.
I FEEL LIKE THEY ARE NOT
EXPLAINING THEMSELVES HERE.
TO LEAVE IT OPTIONAL IS WEIRD.
I HAVE NEVER SEEN GUIDANCE LIKE
THAT.
IT'S WEIRD.
>> AND THERE ARE THESE
SUBJECTIVE THINGS DRIVING IT.
THEY REALIZE PEOPLE WILL START
GET PULLED OUT OF SCHOOLS,
HOSPITALS BECAUSE THEY ARE
TESTING FOR COVID.
I THINK THERE IS A DESIRE TO GET
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE.
THAT'S IN PART DRIVING THIS.
DR. WALENSKY SAID, LOOK, A LOT
OF PEOPLE WEREN'T FOLLOWING THE
10-DAY ISOLATION RECOMMENDATIONS
ANYWAY.
ONLY 10% WERE FOLLOWING THAT.
BUT ALSO THIS IDEA WHEN ARE YOU
CONTAGIOUS AND WHEN DO YOU STOP
BECOMING CONTAGIOUS?
IT'S INTERESTING.
10 DAYS IS WHAT PEOPLE HAVE
BECOME FAMILIAR WITH.
YOU CAN TRACK HOW CONTAGIOUSNESS
DROPS OVER THAT PERIOD OF TIME.
JOHN, IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
SCREEN, DAY FIVE THEY SAY MOST
PEOPLE ARE NO LONGER CONTAGIOUS.
BUT IN FACT, WHAT THE STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN IS BY DAY 5, ROUGHLY
A THIRD ARE STILL CONTAGIOUS.
ADD TO THAT THAT A TEST IS NOT
REQUIRED.
YOU COULD PUT A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE STILL CONTAGIOUS, MAY
NOT KNOW IT THEMSELVES.
.
AND THAT PROPAGATES THE
PANDEMIC.
THAT IS A CONCERN.
THE UK LOOKED AT THE SAME DATA
AND SAID SEVEN DAYS AT LEAST OF
ISOLATION AND TWO NEGATIVE
ANTIGEN TESTS IN ORDER TO LEAVE
EYES LAZE.
WE ARE OBVIOUSLY NOWHERE CLOSE
TO THAT.
>>?
ALL RIGHT.
ALSO THE CDC CONTINUING TO STAND
BY CLOTH MASKS, SUGGESTING CLOTH
MASKS ARE STILL OKAY.
WE HAVE HAD PLENTY OF PEOPLE
COME ON AIR AND SAY, NO, NO, NO.
YOU REALLY NEED SOMETHING MORE
SERIOUS, MORE PROTECTIVE THAN
THAT.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE?
>> YEAH.
THE EXPERTS WE HAVE TALKED TO IN
VIRAL DYNAMICS, BEEN TALKING TO
THEM FOR TWO YEARS.
MARR SAYS GIVEN OMICRON, THEY
ARE NOT GOING TO CUT IT.
ERIN BROMAGE SAID 75% OF
PARTICLES WILL GET THROUGH A
CLOTH MASK.
UNLIKE K-9 5 OR N 95.
95 MEANS 95% ROUGHLY FILTRATION.
BUT ALSO PART OF THIS IS BECAUSE
NOT ONLY ARE THEY HIGH QUALITY
MASKS BUT ALSO THEY HAVE THESE
ELECTRO STATIC FIBERS WITHIN THE
MASK.
IT WILL TRAP SOME OF THE VIRAL
PARTICLES AS WELL.
THAT MAKES IT VERY EFFECTIVE.
IF YOU'RE GOING TO WEAR A MASK,
AND YOU SHOULD, ABSOLUTELY WHEN
YOU GO OUT IN PUBLIC, SHOE WEAR
A GOOD MASK.
FOR A LONG TIME, THESE MASKS
WEREN'T AS AVAILABLE.
DOCTORS LIKE KAREN SAID IF
PEOPLE WORE THESE MASKS FOR FOUR
WEEKS REGARDLESS OF THE TYPE OF
VARIANT, WE COULD ESSENTIALLY
BRING THIS PANDEMIC TO AN END.
WE'RE STILL NOT THERE.
THEY ARE.
MORE AVAILABLE.
PROJECT N 95 IS A NONPROFIT.
CHECK IT OUT.
THERE HAS BEEN AN ISSUE WITH
FRAUDULENT MASKS.
>> AND THE ONES YOU HELD UP ARE
WAY MORE COMFORTABLE.
THEY ARE SO EASY TO WEAR.
IT SEEMS TO ME WHAT THE CDC IS
DOING A CLOTH MASK IS BETTER
THAN NOTHING.
IF T